foreign
's almost upon us and it's about time
for a pre-season preview but didn't I do
that already well I figured that I
should make a secondary list one
focusing on just new anime that way if
you're not looking for sequels you can
have a wider library to choose from
because in hindsight after checking the
seasonal list I saw that there are other
shows coming out this summer that I want
to give some love to so with all the
sequels out of the way here are what I
see is the top 10 most anticipated
titles for summer 2023
let's kick things off now with classroom
for Heroes
yes so why does this one look so
familiar yep it's been quite a while
since we've had these kinds of magic
Academy light novel adaptations and it's
a pretty welcome sight especially given
how much I loved a misfit of Demon King
Academy and akashic Records this time
the setting is at Rosewood Academy the
school for Heroes in training founded by
a powerful hero who once defeated the
Demon Lord in this school that only
accepts the best of the best honest
flaming nicknamed the Empress of flame
stands above them all then in comes a
light-hearted boy named blade he seemed
to come out of nowhere and showed power
that could match her own not only is he
revealed to be Rosewood Academy's newest
transferee Ernest has been personally
requested by the king to show in the
ropes around the academy yes an
adaptation of a novel from 2015. its age
really shows in its premise not that I'm
complaining though because I like these
sorts of stories while I haven't read
the source material a lot of people in
my circles have shown some interest in
this I do think that what we'll be
getting here are some fun character
Dynamics decent action and cute girl
characters if you're around a decade ago
for the Heyday of these shows then and
here's a throwback for you
liar Liars in the next spot
[Music]
is
and thus we go back to another Academy a
different flavor this time though this
time the academy refers to a school the
size of an island where people compete
against each other in games ranks are at
stage and this is a school where
anything can happen especially since new
student hirodo beats the strongest in
the school on his very first day getting
the highest ranking record time is a
ridiculous feat but it does come with a
caveat there's actually more to his win
but as they say a win's a win it's now
up to hirodo to push his wits to their
limits in order to maintain his rank
through lies and Bluffs in a world of
lies and games only the smartest Will
Survive Lyle does have a very
interesting setup it feels like one of
those shows that captivates you with a
charismatic Mastermind lead while
showering you with eye candy it kind of
gives me a whole No Game No Life or
classroom of the elite Vibe going into
it something to look out for if you
enjoy all those big brain psychological
moments in anime along with a dash of
rom-com
[Music]
the amply named Temple is in rank 8. hi
there's really something about religious
figures and relationships with the
opposite gender with all the Oaths and
purity of it all surprisingly we don't
have much media to deal with the premise
and understandably so but here comes
Temple ready to give this premise a
world in the most hilarious and
over-the-top wave akimitsu in spite of
all of his efforts to be cool is
actually a gloomy loner and finds
himself in a compromising situation it's
this situation with a woman that leaves
him determined to pursue his sudden new
goal become a Buddhist monk and renounce
the ways of the world of course things
wouldn't be that simple and it turns out
that the temple that he picked to be his
base of operations isn't your ordinary
Temple it's a temple full of women which
includes the same one he'd found himself
filled with impure thoughts over now
that is a pretty wild premise isn't it
Temple is an adaptation of a popular web
manga that's sure to leave people in
stitches a comedic romance with a dash
of etchy in it is sure to be one of the
knee shits this coming season and if
you're not a verse to any of those
elements then you should definitely give
this one a shot
up next we have new saga
after a climactic battle with the Demon
Lord Kyle emerges Victorious but Victory
doesn't come without its costs he
himself got seriously injured in battle
and that's not even getting into the
casualties leading up to this pivotal
moment just when our heroes on the verge
of death he manages to activate a relic
that quickly sends him to the Past it's
a shocking development but Carl decides
that this is the best time for him to
change the past and avoid all tragedy
time travel fantasy does always have a
cool ring to it but I found it pretty
cool that instead of preventing a bad
ending this story subverts The tried and
true premise and instead focuses on our
protagonists trying to achieve a
different type of Victory as some say
what victory is there if you had to lose
everything to get it and with how easily
you can mess things up in the past it
certainly creates an intriguing Dynamic
that I can't wait to see unfold
I threw it
is
[Music]
now if you missed those good old days of
playing military games taking on enemies
and showing off your skills in piloting
our sponsors of War Thunder may just be
the perfect game for you whether it's
tanks planes warships and such this game
has it all and you can control over 2
000 models as you take the fight to your
foes personally my favorite part of War
Thunder is just how detailed it is I
mean these Graphics look awesome and if
you've got a bit of that history slash
Warfare geek in you perhaps influenced
by shows like anti or girls and Panzer
you'd be seeing a lot of familiar faces
around here all of these come in
exceptionally rendered models that make
the most out of Modern Hardware War
Thunder is the definitive vehicle combat
game for you and you can play on
multiple consoles PC Xbox PlayStation
you name it all for free it even has
anime themed skins so you can make those
memes of anime decals on helicopters
come true if you want to take it further
how about checking out the kisanazu and
these cool 3D daki makuras for you to
show off follow the link in the
description and get started on War
Thunder now it doesn't get any better
than this if we're talking warfare games
and registering on PC will give you an
insane bonus including multiple premium
vehicles and more that's not even
mentioning the exclusive cosmetic that
you can obtain by following my link so
what are you waiting for join The Fray
in War Thunder now right let's get back
to the video Hulk Finds Its way next on
the list
[Music]
Kyle's not the only one who's defeated a
Demon Lord and to help Humanity's
champion and uh Demon Lord candidate you
see after the previous demon Lord's been
defeated the enemies organized the
tournament to determine a worthy
replacement unfortunately the ceremony
to Crown the Lord of demons has none
other than hell himself emerging as the
favorite to win it all all the time he
also can't start ranting about how he
hates Humanity surely something's Amish
here and it's all up to Red vamirio to
uncover the truth behind this Enigma of
a hero this light-hearted manga is
finally set to come to our screens in
the form of an anime Helk has a lot of
moments and in its manga form it does a
masterful job of Shifting tone it's
definitely something that you have to
experience and you'll see that the crazy
premise is just the tip of the iceberg a
teaser to the dramatic moments it has to
share with us
thank you
magic Academy season is not over yet
with reign of the seven spellblades
you thought it was all over with
classroom for Heroes didn't you well how
about something similar which takes a
way darker twist then yep you wouldn't
think that there's anything dark if you
took a passing glance at the prestigious
Magic School Kimberly it's an upbeat
mood Every Spring complete with those
parades and celebrations and that's
exactly what Oliver horn our
protagonists saw at first however the
harsh curriculum is the least of his
worries as dark secrets lie underneath
the academy and never is this more
evident when Knight Falls well Oliver
and his newly acquainted friends be able
to weather the storm when they come face
to face with these secrets reign of the
seven spell blades really UPS the ante
on the usual magic Academy Story with
its much more mature execution well it's
got all the usual Hallmarks of the genre
I really think it will give our fans a
fresher take on the genre one that a
number of them will really enjoy I'm
looking forward to this one
[Music]
dark Gathering is up next and it's
looking real promising
foreign
there seems to be a theme with
Supernatural powers and people who
absolutely want nothing to do with them
it creates a pretty cool dynamic in
terms of kick-starting a story and dark
Gathering is the next example in the
long line of Supernatural stories
starting off with an unwilling
protagonist in this case the focus is on
ketaro and his past traumas something
he's getting help with from childhood
friend Aiko it's a tutoring job that
puts him in an encounter with yayoi
Aiko's cousin and his complete opposite
the Curious Yayo is more than eager to
have her share of spiritual encounters
and it's this that appears to be drag
and getaro back into the world he swore
to never enter again the dangers that
wait in the spiritual realm seem to be
more than what he bargained for for far
too long we anime fans have been
conditioned to think that the
supernatural genre is full of cool
scenes hyped action sequences and the
like so I think it's nice that we'll get
a show that goes back to the roots of
the genre the creepy and the dark as
opposed to what we've been seeing from
the likes of Demon Slayer and with the
suspenseful atmosphere dark Gathering
really does an amazing job of putting
its audience at the edge of their seats
that see how this one translates into
the anime format
[Music]
the girl I like forgot her glasses
starts off our top three
[Music]
there are only so many ways you can set
up a rom-com that's what I'd like to say
the anime just keeps surprising me with
all of these premises Boy Meets Girl
isn't a rare story I'm just amazed by
how many ways that plot can get going in
this case it's all about guy day and the
girl of his dreams I and what sets off
their budding Romance the fact that I
started losing her glasses and our
protagonist is there to help her through
difficulties and that's the premise but
don't let the simple way I describe the
premise fool you okay the series is one
healthy stroke of sweetness all the way
throughout a lot of acute and Charming
interactions between our leads and other
characters and its wholesomeness is
something that some people just won't
get enough of just think something like
Angel spawns been rotten a couple of
months ago and you more or less have the
Vibes that the series gave me in its
comic form this is something great to
relax with and it's coming this summer
[Music]
100 is the second on the list
now here's an anime that I feel has got
an extra layer of relatability to the
newer generation with how Bleak things
seem for the Youth these days compared
to Generations past it's really hard to
look forward to tomorrow we drag
ourselves through life looking to just
tick off a bucket list before our
eventual passing same thing happens to
Akira but maybe all it takes is for one
insane incident to change things around
in a snap in this case a zombie
apocalypse one which pushes all the
plans forward and gives argira some
renewed life brim it with excitement
more than ever he rushes out into the
City full of zombies eager to Kickstart
his life again and finish that bucket
list before all hell breaks loose more
than they already have anyway zom100s a
promising new Saiyan title that's set to
take the World by storm it's got this
light-hearted atmosphere and quirky set
of characters which I think will make it
a hit with its own charismatic Flair to
it definitely one of the more
anticipated titles coming and it will
only keep getting better as the quirky
comedic atmosphere gives way to some
hyped saying in sequences down the line
rounding things off is Rurouni Kenshin
[Music]
Rurouni Kenshin isn't a new anime that
much is clear however it's a remake of a
Timeless classic and not a sequel so I
guess it counts here anyway the
anticipation for this is really big it's
more of a testament as to how fondly
remembered the original series is to be
fair it does deserve it being one of the
pillars of anime breaking cultural
barriers back in the 90s Rurouni Kenshin
is next in line in the Legacy anime
making a return and the series being
reimagined in the modern anime style
does make it a very intriguing project
thematically strong with some emotional
moments and hyped fights I can't wait to
see how well ruroni kenshin's plot has
aged I also can't wait to see how new
anime fans will receive this take on a
very good story of redemption as far as
anticipation goes it's looking really
good from my side of things and the
social media circles I'm in need
[Music]
foreign
if you like the video then don't
hesitate to check out the rest of what
we have in store for you in this channel
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game War Thunder whether it's tanks
planes warships and such this game has
it all and you can control over 2 000
models as you take the fight to your
foes links in the description and I'll
be seeing you on the battlefield thanks
for watching I wish you a good day